everybody welcome back to Kalani Beach
episode 27 and today I won't actually be
building anything but I'll mostly get
into lighting and special effects in the
park and of course I've got the awesome
ladies on you okay we're going to do
that again I've got I've got the awesome
delay designer in here I'm not going to
make that mistake again
hi how are you doing fine but it's the
lady zinger no it's not gone you know
I'm still not like almost every episode
have a nice yeah you did and I'm so
surprised that you're now correcting
yourself like I'm not going to say that
ever again
thanks for you you're even the French I
mean it's the French people who skip out
letters in their work don't they to be
honest English does that kind of as well
you know that sentence where it's like
English is stuff but you can read it
through thorough thought something like
that like there are all kinds of words
that end on the saying that is but you
have to pronounce them differently like
English kind of does that well but yeah
French is probably the worst of it yeah
but anyway yeah anything about currently
[Music]
German is okay though but uh how are you
and Rudy um I'm pretty fun actually
yeah all right hmm and what about you
guys it's a little bit early
we never record this early that's nice
yes it's about 10 a.m. on Saturday as we
speak yeah which is good although what
you doing with the waterfalls yes
goodbye I don't like what you're doing
with the FBI yeah it's great
I'm trying to keep it okay interestingly
this is actually something that I just
took straight out of volcano Bay uh-huh
I think you guys remember that Park it's
the yeah definitely it's the universal
it's the universal theme park in America
with water slides and stuff and it was
actually one of the major inspiration
for a quality bleach when it comes to
the theme and when it comes to having
that volcano in the middle of it and
that's okay now actually has some
waterfalls running down the sides of it
as well and into this pool of water and
I yeah I really thought that the volcano
was kind of looking a little bit boring
and still the entire time so I figured
we might as well try with some
waterfalls and that was the intention
right but I think we all waited because
the FES will drop so hard oh really
yeah I totally think that we wanted to
do something like this because volcano
was it's going to wait beach well why
should you
um forget the name but that was the
inspiration so I thought that we wanted
to make waterfalls out of video cleaner
oh wow yeah I wasn't sure actually but
that is a good point it has definitely
been brought up before as well though
one thing that I'm I'm kind of glad
about is that it doesn't it doesn't ruin
the FPS too much so I think we're still
kind of mine dude so surprised how well
the FPS are I have to say I mean last
time I had to park I was kind of afraid
because you build those amazing slides
again and we had the pool area and you
know the mini golf could come into as
well and then I was like okay let's see
and even though I added about 30,000
pieces again with poly area it's still
okay I guess I it's not as bad as other
parks I had so before you see what I'm
not again right now readings yeah for me
it was actually kind of well one of the
things that is most annoying about the
park it I mean it's got thousands of
pieces I think we measured it recently
and was around 220,000 yes yeah
something like that I think oh yeah that
was when you therus was boasting about
his parking lots being 180 thousand
pieces which it tuned out there wasn't
expecting all those 19,000 features only
nineteen thousand was it for a long time
I can lie that's a low res parking lot
yeah
it's ridiculous by the way for anybody
who is watching this and doesn't know
you to us yet he makes some amazing
videos and his latest alpine park is
really cool so I'll link that in
description you should definitely check
it out especially calling the parking
lot master but amazing it artists as
well definitely yep
so yeah he's got that going on but we
have about 120,000 pieces in this park
so that the frame rate is already kind
of hurting for me it's between 10 and 15
FPS but to be honest it's still you know
it's something that's still quite good
when you look at a game like this if you
can have 120,000 3d items in a single
park or just custom-built in this huge
map and the game doesn't just give up on
everything totally depends on your
computer and that is true on my computer
my computer is kind of kind of a sort of
mid decent it's got a GTX 970 which is
which has become sort of the middle
ground GPU and it's like we're not it's
just a simple I 5 processor yeah I don't
really have the best computer ever
though I definitely know in your
computer it runs like a beast right now
and I'm really happy because if I didn't
have that I should I definitely couldn't
do anything in a park anymore I just I
couldn't already so yeah I'm quite happy
I love that fan by the way with those
lightning lights it's amazing yeah
that's I'm still very simple but it's so
looking good mm-hmm so thankful that you
you're going into action yeah that's
that's really nice yeah right I was just
hard to say it's something that we
always kind of record and just about
everything we do we seem to forget it
like I know I I did Gerudo with Rudy and
we completely forgot about the lighting
and first extreme planet coaster ever
does is they go into the big park and
they're like I wonder what it would look
like at night mm-hmm
so we're not going to make that mistake
ever again if they ever will want to
show off collie Beach I don't know if
they will do because it's so huge but
then we need to make sure we have
lightning this is basically have the
I mean like it's great it's super close
I guess it's also about what you do
right I mean if you if you do like a
restaurant or so it's much more
realistic that you look into lighting
because you you cannot place lights just
for the sake of having those lights
mm-hmm style elements and then you most
likely turn on the knives u.s. well just
to see if that's not too much you know
and then you are going into it but if
you just go entire area you kind of
forget about them
oh I love what you do yeah I have to say
my major inspiration here aside from all
kinds of people in roller-coaster
country who were super amazing at it is
there's a tutorial on a shy guys world I
kind of lost by gerdt which is a weird
name to pronounce but he had a license
before you on shyguys world which is
amazing just for one quote alone like
what he said over there was that
lighting is the painting of the night
like and the one important thing is if
you have to make it in such a way that
that you can navigate through the park
and everything that you have to navigate
through we need to be lit up but also
you need to like light up the few areas
that you can light like you should light
up everything but bring lights to the
few things that you want people to look
at so in some cases you'll bring light
to the parts of a building that look
best and that you want the attention to
go to in some cases you'll bring light
to a little Hut or something of interest
that you want to look at and in some
cases you also want to line up the past
in the past
and one of the amazing tricks that he
brought up in that tutorial as well yeah
was putting those books lights in the
walls along side paths to line up the
paths without actually having lampposts
and it looks like okay I'm definitely
gonna use this in the future I never
ever saw about but that's really really
good mm-hmm thank you and can we just
can we just point out how amazing the
light system is and planet-killers like
yes we didn't talk too much about it I
think they they kind of made a huge step
when they added those two big lights
like that what's this called the big
spotlight and the
mm area light though those gave us a lot
more freedom I guess in terms of
lighting in general but also how
different the the single spots and and
you know those today where I feel like
rather than in the beginning I remember
that in the beginning you had to place
too many lights to get something lit up
and they definitely did some
improvements of that as well I think
personally actually because I like the
large light as well but I think they're
best suited for really large things like
lighting of supports of coasters of or
lighting a very large thing for me
actually the big improvement was being
able to choose our own colors for the
lights like choose how much they light
up so you can really mute the lights but
you can also make a very harsh and
bright yeah sure definitely also bigger
I really like how you just lit up all
the trees right now just to see some
shades on it it's so beautiful I mean
really inspiring also it's always crazy
to see how many lights in the real
impact would also be because I think
it's pretty realistic how you have to
put all those spots down like in real of
so you also need to have a lot of lights
to to lit up those areas I think always
so interesting to see and then you can
also judge parks will make a really
brilliant job to hide them away so like
you know it's it's also hard to kind of
position them in a way that you can't
see them on daylight yeah much so it was
actually yeah that was one of the things
which I thought made lighting a lot of
fun because it's kind of like a puzzle I
wanted all the lights that I use in the
park here to all be visible so well
they're not they're not there's no
invisible yeah I tried to make them
visible in a way that I wouldn't like
dragged them underground or into scenery
objects like all the things that emit
lights are at least visible but they're
as hidden as possible kind of in a sense
and I wanted to avoid using the large
area lights
the enormous plot line actually soon as
those kind of light things up too much
the only areas where I really use them
are for the wooden coaster supports for
example or lighting up the volcano but
there I'm totally spoiling things but
yeah I think that's what they are
supposed to be like right so I think
it's just that they added those were
just as lady said already so good to
avoid closing down millions of those
spots to be able to and sink them into
each other because you can make the
light stronger and bigger if you sink
them into each other again and again I
think the best the best thing about it
that we do have the possibility now to
make this without yes just me only thing
that still annoys me are those signs
you're aligned not the signs some of the
signs have like those bright letters but
some have just like a weird oh yes a day
to just color very weird in my opinion
when you put on a put a light on in
that's true to be honest that the
science in general are still one of my
major gripe in the game because the
young the poems don't really translate
that well into the size of the signs
yeah but I think things are gonna change
now a little bit with the billboards a
little bit not and finally I guess it's
a good point actually you can just make
signs out of those billboards right
actually may a deal also the only thing
I'm a little bit afraid of this and I
maybe that's the first thing I'm going
to feedback because I'm not too sure
about it right now but it would be so
cool if we can somehow I don't know not
turn off the spill but screen but make
it not glow in the darkness I'm a little
afraid how this will work with kind of
you know just really mute assign colors
also if you put down and it's still
glowing like a big screen you know it
would be nice like for example wouldn't
billboards where you would paint on yeah
they just don't glow
so for my taste we don't need to be able
to put down videos on those screens but
at these images
yeah then that they are not just you
know not at right yeah not not right at
all so that they don't know ourselves
that we have to put some spots on it to
make
yeah that would be a pretty nice
position because I'm a little afraid
that if you do place so many signs are
kind of custom textures all the way
along life because I was already
thinking of building a yeah just making
a building out of walls out of those
things you know and when it's going to
be blowing themselves you got a big
building blowing itself which yeah Mike
yeah say may I just say that I love how
you use these colors oh yes that's
beautiful
oh thanks thank you does Wow
okay I think it's something important
since the rest is all just kind of
orange shitless like Josh it's amazing I
would never thought of anything like
this
no but as you do it I just wanted to add
that the sequencer is coming this might
be an idea to have a really gentle wave
of colors going through the support of
the wooden coat let's let Matt actually
that's amazing
those are we so awesome but then again
you can't really put in how much they
will just flicker on and off so they
don't yeah but you can put like multiple
lamps in a row and just one on for each
part of the sequence yeah you can try
there there was also tutorial I thought
also in Chagas walls to make lights
blend into each other it's pretty simple
you just need to have the same color
twice and then you you just take the one
color you want to blend into the other
one and put the for example let's say
you want to go from yellow to green and
then you have the yellow one and you
copy the yellow one move it slightly to
the right and also think in the new one
the green one then we have to trigger
like the first yellow one is going off
but the other yellow one is staying on
while the green one is turning on as
well and then like for example the 0.1
seconds later the second yellow one is
turning off so that you can just while
you just turn on the green one you had
left a little bit of yellow light and go
into the next one so that's not really a
nice way to to have explained without
looking like the next one is going on
I see I see the next issue I'm really
hoping that they gonna change it the
water that needs to be lit up or shimmer
at nighttime because yeah
it just doesn't look natural at all
right now it looks very much like jello
at night which is kind of over the same
kind of happens in the shadow because as
far as I know lighting a day has no
effect on the water so if water is in
like the shadow part of for example this
volcano it still has the same amount of
lighting as any part so it'll be a lot
lighter than and then the surroundings
mm-hmm that's really no I can kind of
see why it is that way because the
particle effects or religious particle
effects they're just a bunch of pipes
going down an emitter which they would
have to admit shadows and all of the
separate particles at all times which is
impossible like you cannot render that
but it is a very good point I would I
wish I want to make water shows at my
side with day shows know that it doesn't
look Wow
if you can't put any lights or me like
that on the water so I tried like in
alpha 2 1 alpha 2 where we got DZ of X's
and it was like I'm going to make like
that huge purple tree of avatar and then
I just found out after places like a
hundred see of access that it definitely
had help at night it was like okay
nevermind [ __ ]
yeah it really was and and that since
then I'm always like oh it so much but
they will change that at some point that
it will lit up when you put in a light
on the water will be so cool maybe they
could do something similar to
rollercoaster country with water shows
though because it has the same issue
with the textures and not being able to
light up water but what you were able to
do in the water shows for rollercoaster
country is give the water a color so we
all have like water that looked like it
was little you would just give it a
light color it's not the perfect
connection but actually works
and in general my next meal a up yeah
but I think that's a good one if it's I
mean that's paying respect to what
particle effects are like right so I
think it's the most easy thing may be
that easy in general but the most easy
thing is to to just let us change the
color of the particle effects that would
also give us maybe the possibility to do
some other crazy stuff particles oh yeah
we could make like blood rivers and
stuff I don't know why that was the
first thing I told us but I'm already
know there's the Middle East in the UK
which is a question light goes over like
glow to waterfalls and stuff oh yeah
that's right really yeah you can do some
interesting stuff with that or you can
make a radioactive water and have it be
green Wow okay why not or or you could
just make a chocolate River and make a
real joining the chocolate egg through
ya know many people mentioned that on my
Wonderland series take a travel trip
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory dark
ride with real dark water brown water
and I'm like yeah I don't know that well
you know that's a grin like I'm just an
idea for fun - yeah I guess yeah that's
a good idea for fun - yeah but we are
just being so negative of all the stuff
that is welcoming or remains I'm
starting by saying how amazing it was I
just can't wait for the fireworks guys
yep going to be so awesome and we're
gonna happen throughout the film in this
park as well absolutely absolutely
alongside with the wave over the support
oh no damn that I mean like though hi so
why do we do a firework we have so many
possibilities
oh I ain't just surrounding them so pain
or anything like that but really at the
middle point of the park you could also
be very cheeky and have it come out of
the volcano that also but no not that's
about how it looked
I'm just so curious how it will look
when you put it in order so I think it
might be the best
there are no viable effects and there
should be or something like an explosion
like have fireworks from the lake and
then an explosion in the volcano to make
it look as the local intersection like
this I would be so cold
yeah and then we gotta have blood water
running down which is actually not blood
water melted stone cold lava right oh
that's something you could make it to
look at the color the particle effects
as well get room absolutely
wow it's already over it is I went too
fast
now that's didn't just fun it for the
time that's it's literally the lighting
for the entire park so there are still
some parts that need to be lit up
especially around the new areas and the
pool and stuff but uh I think in the end
like we just talked about like when
probably will be the end of quality
Beach because you're leaving to Tokyo
mm-hmm and I'm just yeah really sad and
I think we seriously need to spend like
maybe three episodes which is putting
everything together and make it look
perfect in the end I think it's going to
take a long time and actually spend on
ion management stuff and and yeah
everything is going raizy not just
customizing a customization and and
fireworks and fired
yeah I think it's gonna take us a long
time as well and I still think we need
one more coaster because like comment by
going crazy about one more coaster so
even though I don't know which ones that
and people are asking for dark rides but
I don't think we will have the time for
that consider right now doc right is
they're super amazing and I've seen so
many great ones already but for me
personally it's like the most time
intensive thing yeah to do true and I
don't really feel like doing at her
quality Beach not with knowing that it's
probably be ending at the end of August
for those who are wondering
yep that's basically where we've kind of
set the deadline so we're going to do an
R up things well we still got a lot more
weeks to come
even with it - I'm nine weeks two months
in a week I know him and for next week
yeah I'm not really sure if we can do it
is we got the Ashley meetup going on and
the update is coming so I'm going to try
to make sure I have an episode next week
what else really rain Colonel we'll be
covering it because you have some more
time I guess and so yeah we're just so
pretty talk about one with the next one
yeah but it's just good to mention for
the people that are waiting for my
channel it could be also on Gritty rank
ml Channel next week so that depends a
little bit how everything is going next
week yeah just call Ian's thing yeah
anything anything Mitchell means about
that yeah yeah do that
did you see the picture on Twitter I
posted Oh team I could I couldn't avoid
that my Twitter went crazy when you see
my light AdvoCare is there was fun to
have a picture of the three of us but I
like I like the commons most with Harry
Ron and Hermione yeah it was actually
perfect like hairstyles middle one
having blossoms and everything okay yeah
okay so if you're the one who has to
kill Voldemort now we still the man who
watched it so I'm trying to break as a
community no you're a wizard silver I'm
not you know until Harry Potter's
actually go along with this because I've
watched it when I was younger but I
haven't actually done a marathon in any
recent years so I'm not the references
but I'm the lucky one
I'm the damp one who's always with us
and go get video at the end and we got
super halt in the end like Siri you do
ready
that's my tall so I'm pretty sure that
guy like what's he called Rupert
like yet been like known to drive around
in an ice cream truck and hand out ice
creams and children yeah for free yes
that's so amazing
yes yeah we graduated is about it so
guys if you want to spend look just go
Rupert Grint ice ice truck like I don't
think it's time to rip it up yeah I
started to I'm gonna try to fit in some
cinematic shorts and stuff yeah well you
have like some remark to show at
nighttime so you we find yeah it looks
really sexy at night so tournaments are
intense
so yeah open it for today thank you guys
for watching thank you really and lady
for being here
yeah it's been awesome and I'll see you
guys next week on either the ladies or
release channel bye bye guys